nicht lang schnacken kopf hinweg
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute gibt 360 zu bereiten werde wir
haben nämlich vor kurzem da waren wir in
einem hotel unter gab es eine karte und
daraus konnte man sich jeden tag so ein
saft zu bereiten oder zubereiten lassen
und die waren echt ziemlich lecker und
als ich neulich hier ganz spontan auf
instagram selbst dazu bereitet habt war
wirklich ganz auf die nachfrage nach
weiteren saft rezepten und deswegen
heute drei davon ich habe mir jetzt zum
einen den ersten saft ausgesucht da
heißt achtung karotte kit
[Musik]
statik ist karate kid und ich habe jetzt
gerade entdeckt da gibt es immer so ein
text dazu schnell sich das mal vor also
normalerweise ist in karate kid karotte
ehrt artischocke birne irgendwas throne
er hatte schon mitbekommen
deswegen habe das sind weggelassen also
erste schock ist einfach topinambur
erdapfel nennen wir das auch vielleicht
hätte ich doch noch bekommen und könne
in dem anderen egal ihr könnt gerne mit
dazu nehmen und da war immer so ein
kleiner text dabei acht bester schüler
der cobra karate gang topinambur
bekämpft giftstoffe die unfassbare birne
schlägt infektionen die unglaubliche
karotte stopp schmerzen der großmeister
ingwer trainiert das immunsystem zuerst
zu schlagen fahrt zu schlagen keine
krankheit verdient die niederlage bei
[Gelächter]
ich weiß es nicht kann man nur sagen die
säfte waren sei lecker und ich kenne die
rezepturen nicht aber mein gott ist den
säfte ich nehme jetzt dafür wie karotten
das sind bio karotten und deswegen
brauche ich die jetzt auch nicht so
schälen
einsatz von einer zitrone zwei birnen da
könnt ihr euch die sorten aussuchen je
weiter die birne unser süßer ist sie
dann umso reicher ist sie auch und etwas
ingwer und wenn ihr habt gerne noch
erdapfel ich bereit das ganze gleich
hier im slot es dazu von der kenwood die
kitchenaid hat zum beispiel auch den
aufsatz als entsafter hat und so einen
user ist muss man das logo seines lotus
hat man von diesem vorteil dass wirklich
gar keine reibe wärme entsteht und die
vitamine und die inhaltsstoffe einfach
schöne enthalten bleiben wenn ihr keinen
intakter habt könnt ihr auch alle
zutaten nähen mit wasser verdünnen und
das ganze mixen oder habt ihr einen
leckeren smoothie ist von der konsistenz
her anders aber man hat im prinzip alles
mit drin und hat auch keine abfallstoffe
also dann hier oben einfach nur ist von
der karotte wegnehmen wie gesagt er muss
man sie nicht ohne
zur seite die birne die schneide ich
jetzt einfach nur so dass er durch die
öffnung da oben passt die muss man auch
nicht entfernen und nicht fehlen es darf
alles mit rein
[Musik]
bei den karotten muss ich nur gucken die
ganz dicken muss ich so ein bisschen
halbieren weil die da oben ansonsten
nicht durch fassen ja und dann einfach
hier auf der maschine stufe 2 bis 3
ungefähr und dann geht's los hier den
behälter für den saft hier oben dass ich
erst mal noch zu
und dann kann hier der trester also der
rest praktisch ablaufen und da reinfall
[Musik]
und hier am besten nicht drücken nicht
stopfen schreitet das obst und gemüse
gerne ein bisschen kleinere teile oder
als größere war so dass die maschine
sich das obst und gemüse ziehen kann und
dann arbeitete von ganz alleine und man
hat wirklich gar keine probleme auf
damit einfach nur alles da oben rein
und die zitrone könnte jetzt entweder
viele tiere obendrein geben oder ihr
könnt einfach denn sagt auspressen
[Musik]
entstehen dann immer noch ein bisschen
mit kaltes wasser und gibt es noch
hinterher dann spürt einfach nochmal
alle gäste aus und auch so zum
saubermachen ist es dann halt viel
einfacher der saft ist dann auch gleich
ein bisschen verträumt dann ist er nicht
ganz so konzentriert schmeckt uns
persönlich auch besser
das war
eine flasche von caro karotte clips oft
da kommt ihr zitronensaft treiben
[Musik]
und das hier ist der trester also der
rest sozusagen bei dem smoothie hätte
man diesen rest des nicht da wird mit
den rest sozusagen mit trinken was jetzt
noch damit waren können ihr könnt zum
beispiel wenn ihr brot backt das ganze
einfach mit dem brotteig dazu geben oder
auch bei dem kuchen mit dazu geben wenn
ihr es nicht sofort verwenden wollte
könnte es auch einfrieren und später
einfach verwenden oder ihr könnt im der
automaten dürren und trocknen und dann
später eben auch mal bei einem boot
meter zu geben also wegschmeißen muss
man es nicht würde ich jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt dass er praktisch da
ausgedrückt ist und fast
geschmacksneutral ist obst und gemüse so
als rest aber trotzdem hat mir da schon
noch nährstoffen mit drin und auch noch
geschmack mit drin und konsistenz und
feuchtigkeit wobei ich sagen muss dass
restfeuchtigkeit also man sieht es ja
ganz gut eigentlich gar nichts mehr drin
als man kann es auch nicht ausdrücken es
ist wirklich richtig schön trocken
damit eben hier der schöne sache dass
mit den ganzen nährstoffen und stehen
werde ich jetzt gleich modul abgewehrt
und dann gibt es noch saft zwei und drei
jetzt mache ich hier den zweiten satz
das ist der mister sellerie mit der
sellerie besteht aus sellerie stangen
staudensellerie etwas petersilie da
nehme ich jetzt die glatte petersilie
eine gurke zwei grüne äpfel limettensaft
und spinat und wenn ich mehrere säfte
nacheinander mache dann brauche ich
jetzt nicht jedes mal der im saft
auseinander sondern ich gebe da einfach
einmal wasser durch dann spüre ich
sozusagen den orangensaft raus und hab
dann eben wieder eine saubere maschine
für den anderen also was ich tatsächlich
bei säften nicht mache und das kann man
sich ganz gut merken wenn ich was grün
ist habe dann bereit ich wirklich nur
den grünen warf zu wenn ich etwas rotes
habe oder was euro schluss das passt
ganz gut sein aber wenig grün und rot
oder grün und orange nicht dann kommt
braun dabei raus und das ist echt schön
schmeckt auch nicht lecker und vor allem
sieht sie nicht appetitlich aus weil ich
finde so der orangene sagt da sie
perfekt aus wäre da jetzt aber ein
bisschen grün dabei dann aber jetzt kann
ich damit trinken und ungeschminkt sind
auch nicht auch bei smoothies mich also
rot zu rot grün zu grün und nicht
mischen jetzt tritt einmal beim spülen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und hier eigentlich das gleiche spiel
auch wieder alles so stüeken dass es
passt bei der petersilie ist immer
schauen wir den guten entsafter habt
dann könnt ihr das mit durch geben
ansonsten könnt ihr aber auch die
petersilie erstmal pürieren mit wasser
zum beispiel und dann eben zum sagt mit
dazu geben aber ich finde es immer ganz
praktisch wenn man alles in einem gerät
machen kann da hat man nicht eine
doppelte arbeit aber die petersilie
hatte im prinzip nicht so viel wasser
sondern muss eben nur zerkleinert werden
deswegen gebe ich dir später dazu wasser
drauf und dann dürfte es auch wieder
machen
[Musik]
und dieses satte grün das kommt gleich
möchte nicht genannt
das ist schade
[Musik]
also hier muss man dazu sagen spinat
petersilie und sellerie ist sehr
fraglich da muss man ein bisschen
achtgeben dass der einsatz hat es auch
ganz gut schafft wie gesagt haben sonst
und einfach mit dem smith i make up zu
bereiten und wenn wir das ganze etwas
süßes haben wollte weil ich weiß dass
viele säfte etwas was ich zum beispiel
dann nehmt ihr einfach mehr äpfel wenn
ihr das nicht so süß haben wir dann
nehmt ihr mehr sellerie und mehr gemüse
ja ich hab das jetzt bei uns relativ
ausgeglichen gemacht dass es dem bugrad
auch schmeckt und den kindern und jetzt
auch wieder mit wasser nachspülen kurz
sauber machen und dann gehts noch saft
drei
stücken ja und schon sind ist und mit
den ganzen grünen stoffen drin das ende
ist
ballack muss
[Musik]
sie
wirkte sich ca
wir verlangen
vitamin
a liga warnte
ban
roter hut oder
kappe
von unserer pläne
dafür gleich zwei profi tester hier
muss
ein kamerateam
32 reiche sagte mister sellerie noch
vorlesen
sellerie und spinat regen das
immunsystem an und helfen den körper zu
reinigen
nein nicht wegen der kinder in farbe was
man vermuten könnte sondern wegen einer
komplizierten chemischen substanz namens
lulin sie helfen auch der blutzucker
gesund erhalten und das gewicht zu
regulieren
klaus meine und
jetzt kommt noch die nummer drei für die
nummer 3 haben wir unseren namen
überlegt wie war der name bietet bietet
das hier heißt jetzt bietet der bietet
saft wegen der roten beete wir nehmen
rote beete davon etwa 200 gramm etwas
ingo zwei karotten drei äpfel und
zitrone bei der roten beete einfach mal
aufpassen handschuhe verwenden die mache
ich zum schluss alles andere bereit ich
jetzt wieder vor und wenn ihr rote bete
nicht so gewohnt seid die frische rote
beete dann nicht zu viel davon auf
einmal trinken ich weiß noch meine
allererste mein allererstes muss mit
rote beete
warte ich lese den text zu fördern
können durch den recht dazu denken
der text dazu lautet
moment gesichtserkennung jetzt
apfel reduziert entzündungen und
beschützt sie bete und karotte bringen
den verdauungstrakt zum lächeln wenn ihr
wisst was freuen bildlich ab was die
werden ganz bestimmt lächeln trinken sie
einfach dem saft und schauen sie ihnen
spiegeln und jetzt lächeln die frage wer
die texte geschrieben hat ich glaube die
haben es auf türkisch geschrieben und
dann einfach per google translate
irgendwie verso irgendwie muss es
gewesen sein jedenfalls bringt rote
beete den verdauungstrakt wirklich zum
das kurbelt inhalt an und wenn ihr eine
komplette knolle einen tag lang über
irgendwie trinkt oder verzerrt dann
müsste öfter mal auf die toilette
deswegen übertreibt es nicht auf einmal
[Musik]
ich will wirklich handschuhe anziehen
sonst verfärbt sich alles
[Musik]
später hatte ich eine wahnsinnige ferber
eigenschaft also damit wurde früher
alles gefährt kleidung haare alles was
man so in rot färben wollte aber
irgendwann kam kamin das wird dann
einfach günstiger hergestellt und dann
is made bestehen kamin sind blattläuse
rote beete hat tolle vitamine als ich
würde eher sagen steigt wieder auf die
rote bete um die hatten einen leicht
erdigen geschmack nicht jeder mag eine
rote bete aber wenn man die gut
kombiniert karte 10 mit karotte mit der
säure der zitrone und mit der süße der
apple und bisschen irgendwann dann
schmeckt rote beete echt extrem gut und
mein lieblings salat zum beispiel ist
sogar rote beete salat also eine meiner
lediglich fanatisch auf recht viele aber
rote beete gedünstet oder eben gekocht
mit einem tollen dribbling ist echt sehr
sehr lecker ich mag's von gern aber wie
gesagt an schuld trage da jetzt noch 14
nummer drei da bin ich ja froh dass
meine schwiegermama hat bei der rote
beete dazu kam weil ich glaube da hätte
das gesicht richtig verzogen gesetzt
nicht getrunken noch gehört beim grünen
hat sich schon gut aber ich glaube jetzt
ganz gut geschmeckt jetzt hier auch
einfach im wechsel immer arbeiten immer
mal welches obst härteres obst so
entlastet er die maschine auf
[Musik]
das habe ich hier alle drei säfte
gemacht hier kommt nach zitrone mit dazu
zitrone sorgt zum einen immer dafür dass
er eine säure in euren säften und zum
anderen dass das eisen zum beispiel in
den äpfeln oder auch allgemein andere
vitamine einfach nicht oxidieren
deswegen immer schön zitronensaft
dazugeben dann werden die säfte nicht
braun
so jetzt mache ich hier kurz sauber wie
gesagt den entsafter werde ich jetzt
einmal wasser durchfließen lassen das
ganze auseinanderbauen und daneben
verstauen und ich dachte dann gleich
noch schotter probieren ob ihr die säfte
auch schmecken und die trester reste die
werde ich dann entweder trocknen oder
ich werde morgen zum großteil wieder zu
geben euro kat rote beete ist perfekt
weil da könnt ihr echt ne ganz ganz
tolles programm im sechzehner utah kommt
jetzt gibt es ja ähnlich
ich liebe rote beete und
vor allem wenn man rote beete salat hat
und dann noch dazu joghurt ist dann wird
es so schön pink okay das habe ich noch
nie gemacht joghurts modebild
es doch zu allem joghurt aber uns ist es
so alles wird mit joghurt er im wasser
beachten müsst bei selbstgemachten
säften dass man die natürlich durch
rhythmus weil setzt sich natürlich
trotzdem
ruhig wird
mit dem harmloseste jetzt wird es ja
herr rothe kit
hmm lecker
ich glaube das können wir kinder können
ja
das ist richtig richtig richtig gut sind
nicht leicht scharf mit dem ingwer also
wenn kinder irgendwann nicht vertragen
einfach irgendwo weglassen aber aber
durch die birne
wichtigste ich etwas sagen diese
gekauften karl ottes auf den mag ich
nicht so hart aber es ist so selbst
gepresst schon okay er ist supergut
niedergedrückt ich weiß jetzt wie
kritisch das ist mein liebling mit
sellerie nicht lang schnacken kopf merkt
[Musik]
also dass meine schwiegermama da nicht
ausgeflippt ist weiß ich auch nicht weil
ich ich hätte es gedacht die trink den
garnett und verzieht die ganze zeit das
gesicht ja
also ich find die wird sich gedacht habe
mein amazon
[Gelächter]
aber man kann mehr apfel und einer
chance
wenn ich gut ja ja was sagt die beiden
was gibt es noch für den trinkspruch
[Musik]
und trotzdem
weiß ich muss in fairer weise
durchführen weil wir jetzt da oben das
ganze buch gleich aber muss ich
fairerweise hier
sie hat noch einen schock trinke ich
habe ja alles versaut so
jetzt ja jetzt fließt
dakota
[Gelächter]
ja
ich mag die rote beete geschmack ich
hatte andere in der partei ja das stimmt
wäre zur rudelbildung
sobald ich mal hin werferin
doch sehr sehr gut also wie gesagt diese
drei hefte dürft ihr gerne mal
ausprobieren
rot orange grün schreibt mir gerne euren
favoriten auf und vielleicht habt ihr
auch saft rezepte dann schreibt sie
gerne in die kommentare dann probiere
ich gerne auch mal eure kombis oder ihr
könnt ihr einfach mal so um zusammen
würfelspiel machen du weißt ihr schreibt
zutaten in die box oder in die
kommentare und wir suchen uns dann die
kombis raus so eine art challenge und
dann probieren wir einfach selbst
dadurch hab ich ein schlepper nein
während sohn er auch keinen grund habe
ich einen neuen job sehr gut also dann
viel spaß beim nachmachen
[Musik]